what are the hazards
the hazards already are
we know that if i didn't tip
this arm hits this muscle
and it doesn't come off so the tip has
to be done within the movement
now you could say but since you're
saying keep this online and if you take
it over there shouldn't i keep it there
the answer is no because you do this you
take their mind with your tummy you tip
this hand comes here on top of your head
it then
as i turn
slowly you'll notice how
my arm still on my head
but now as i
step in
i put her back in a straight line
i don't want her leaning on me
what happens is if you do it wrong
so we we
we've come out if i do it wrong and i
bring this arm here
what happens is jenny's like leaning on
me what where she weighs 18 stone or
something that's unbalanced
and now i've got to throw somebody
so so you can't do that's why you leave
the arm
uh
yeah
this comes on the head
you turn the hips the same as a rotary
door you don't you don't start waving
this about
you blend
and as
i'm going to step in
the arm makes contact quick in case they
took their arm away
i've got here
and then i'll do this
she's not leaning on me
and she's
falling apart and she's wondering what's
happening what's happening because it's
really inquisitive because in training i
now pull it in and i let go of that
but only then
on the end let go down
and then
so
that's why i'm telling you not to pull
the arm in
yeah
so if it's up here and not in your head
then that you're almost broken away
there's a big gap between her
and me
so she could put her arm away and just
walk away
you've got to think of real situations
you've got milli seconds to make a
a decision and your hands got about to
get it quick
see
so slow motion that's what i'm doing
now where is it you see it's going to
come all the way back down here
and your head
hips like mighty door you don't move
your arm
until you step in
each other
this is all this is all part of this
molding of your body
then the techniques become
endured and beautiful and technically
correct
everything went here so i can
tell you
oh yes
i won't do the cutting here but the
category is when you step out of the way
again so you're saying please go pass
you run down here you rub down the arm
you don't just take it off again in case
you need to grab it quick you then step
out the way and you fold it you keep on
your key as you
bring them down you then cross this leg
up over there
and you try to and
you try to keep it on your gear
all right so you try to keep it on your
key
and then this one
one
two
or
i so this is winning
on win rather than
accommodating my partner
so this one
i have to
learn how to
get it here
this way
so we're going to do this one
this one's going to come up
down